a boy Joe Koy just hosted the Golden
Gloves a lot of uh reactivity
online Joe not very proud of his
performance did you see him on Good
Morning America when they asking him
about it I read some of his comments I
don't know I not very happy about it
thoughts on the whole thing did you guys
we all watch it yeah we watched it I
mean tough to take it on 10 days for
that audience is like it's kind of a
nightmare situation also following
arguably the
best version of that ever yeah Ricky
killing it Ricky yeah that's the
expectation okay um Al thoughts I don't
know why any comedian wants to do that
bro so that's an interesting one right
there too like it's an incredibly
difficult uh job to win at you're
performing in front of quite possibly
the worst crowd to perform in front of
meaning everybody there is already
pretty self-absorbed I mean they're
actors right or filmmakers uh they're
artists artists we are self-absorbed
like the're part of this ilk not only
that they're acutely aware that the
cameras are on them so Timothy sham and
the the Jenner girl Kylie Kylie having
this moment where she's fixing a TI both
of them know that there's a camera right
here and they're playing up how cute
they could Poss Taylor Swift and Selena
Gomez and the other girl gossiping all
together but they know everybody is
everybody is aware that the camera's on
them nothing's candid about the
situation at all so they're not you you
have to snap them out of their own head
which is I'm being watched we've all had
a conversation in front of cameras right
have you ever had one where like it's
like for example an interview right
after a fight or something like that
where the camera is a guy holding it
right here and then the interview is
trying to have like a normal
conversation with you or like vloggers
will do this yeah there's a giant light
on the [__] I remember the first time I
think it was a Mike MAAC came over Mike
and Logan came over for it was like a
Super Bowl this is when we were back in
Miami and he started having a normal
conversation while his buddy was like
filming and I and I was like what's
going on right now and then I was like
oh yeah this is this is what vlogging is
essentially when we're doing it on the
road it feels less uncomfortable cuz
we're talking to the camera guy it's
intentional Shifty hey baa hey but this
was what I'm saying is it creates a very
uncomfortable environment okay now how
do you win in that room what did [__]
Ricky do so
well he opens up by saying I don't want
to be here I don't give a [__] I don't
care about this I literally don't I have
my beer half drink up here this is not a
big deal for me and then he
patronizingly says Guys these are jokes
I know you're self-absorbed actors that
take way too seriously but these are J
so he's already going we're at school
you guys are the children yeah
and and we we believe him when he says
and we believe him when he says it and
he don't got to give a [__] he made all
the money he got the hit shows he got
the huge tour we and he goes out there
and he doesn't give a [__] which is
intoxicating to people in Hollywood
because they give so much of a [__] they
want it so badly that night that night
they're auditioning for their next movie
and their next movie after that and
there's an award on the line and their
clients have an award and everyone's
thinking about that they've worked their
whole life for this they're not worried
about your stupid little jokes they're
like get it out of the way did I win did
I win did I win or the did the movie I'm
in win and then I can get this other
thing they're trying to Schmo with a
director that they might have had a
connection with they're like oh when
that director goes to the bathroom I'm
also going to the bathroom and I'm going
to go meet him and my agents their the
whole thing I'm imagining is this this
this this networking moment that they
believe is going to change change your
whole [__] lives nightm would love
that [__] oh a master he be master that
that just sounds like that so what Ricky
did great was he goes all of you guys
care about this I don't give a [__] and
y'all know I don't have to give a [__]
and I'm going to make fun of your asses
and when you don't react I don't give a
[__] equally and if you watch that he
doesn't care when the jokes don't get
the reaction that they do deserve the
jokes are great yeah and I think what
happened with Joe is and even from Joe
coming on the pot and talking about I
think he really did care it and he
talked about it it was an important
moment for him and his family and
everything that he worked for and
everything he came from to be there for
that moment and then when he started to
get maybe the reaction that Mo most H
most most hosts
get I think it rattled him a little bit
M because it wasn't the massive last
that he's used to yeah he's just a
killing in an arena exactly where it's
just whereas Rick's like I know what
this [__] room is going to be I know
that they're going to grow I know that
they're going to be [__] and then
eventually I'm going to bowl them also
the fourth time Ricky hosted fifth time
fourth or fifth yeah so and I think that
he reacted to that lack of reaction you
could tell that he really wanted to win
and succeed in that moment whereas Ricky
wanted to it felt like he wanted to
troll him a bit and I think that's the
best position to be in as the host you
got to want to make him grown you got to
want to make him uncomfortable that's
the win it's almost for us as an
audience we like to see them squirm we
want to see the closeup of Tom Hanks we
all love feeling a little uncomfortable
about a joke we [__] love that and um
along with just you know you got to have
like amazing jokes that let them know
you don't care if they like you or not M
and they react to that that's the big
thing like you got to not want to be in
Hollywood because those jokes actually
might cut deep and somebody be like yo
[__] that guy you making fun of this
director and he's like all right well
you don't need to be in my movies
anymore now the guy who goes I don't
care if I'm in your movies or not that
director is going to go I kind of want
to work with that gu
yeah so I I think you either need that
if you're a comic or you just get like a
TV dude that's like a regular kind of
milk toast host that's going to like
make some cutesy jokes and just let it
be that exactly yeah yeah but that's not
going to slap no but but if you're a TV
guy you don't need to necessarily be
funny you just need to like make a fun
environment you know okay yeah you can
do it with music I think they did that
once with the oxar there was like a lot
of songs or something like like a CEST
like give me person like like that yeah
or you know there's different ways I
think to do it but the expectation will
definitely change but I think when you
have a comic up there now you have the
expectation it's going to be really
funny when you have a non-funny person
up there reading a prompter and it's a
little bit funny you give it a little
bit more ah gotcha gotcha got you know
what I mean it's like a fat person
dancing like if they've got some
coordination you're like oh look at this
fat piece of [__] right a girl hits a
three-pointer you're likeo how'd she do
it that's awesome she did her little
steep in like a [__] grabbing
something
from yeah he's like good job like a
raccoon yeah so so yeah it's it's a
tough situation whenn A Certain style is
definitely going to work for it like Joe
is so Charming on stage that room they
don't want you to charm them yeah they
don't want it they they're like we do
the Charming we are the likable ones
this is about a you don't need to charm
us and Ricky was like I'm not going to
charm you I'm going to [__] roast you
all into Oblivion yeah and then they
then they start laughing cuz they're
like well I don't want to be the one
that like doesn't get the jokes they're
all still in their head about how
they're being perceived and then once
the jokes are about them they're going
well if I don't laugh I look like the
person that doesn't have a good sense of
humor and isn't willing to laugh at
myself I better start laughing yeah see
if you do laugh and you're the only
person that's laughing then it's like
wait am I condoning something that I'm
going to look crazy for Hollywood is a
race to be second that's what they say
about everything with movies with with
TV shows but also with reacting to the
comic yeah that's on there so I think
Joe is beating himself up about it was
it Joe's best performance no but maybe
now maybe now he knows how to win that
environment or maybe he's like that's
not how I want to win it you know maybe
that's not the thing that I want to do
with my skill set M you know and it's
probably even harder for him seeing the
reception online because like you know
most of his stuff he's playing to his
fans his comedy is great so it's I don't
think he's probably ever had to have
public to deal with the masses like that
yeah I mean he's used to performing for
you know 10,000 15,000 people every
single night in destroying exactly yeah
so that [__] has to be rough and you're
in front of people you [__] admire
like it's also hard I can imagine
literally him talking about his mom
loving Merill Street you don't think
that that's playing in his head like
there's part of it's like holy [__] this
woman is my mother looked up to this
woman so much I've created a deity out
of her yeah and now I'm in this kind of
awkward situ situation you know yeah and
then also like the mix like this is
something cassetta pointed out like the
mix from the room and how we actually
hear it the structure of the room is
actually important to that point yeah
that also everyone in that lower Basin
it's not aess it's a the A+ list and
they get one guest to be with them in
the back second layer of it's it's at
the Beverly Hilton it's a mix of like
young younger agents people on the team
Studio Executives uh HF PA and their
their guests there's like a it it just
gets busier back there so you can hear
the laughs more in the back but everyone
in the front knows that they're
potential victim but also like those
first few jokes got a slap those first
few jokes got aone set a tone they got a
bite and they got to let you know like I
think Ricky's first joke was something
about um Felicity Huffman yeah yeah yeah
my license plate said something Felicity
Huffman actually made it Felicity
Huffman is an actress that's in jail
because of that uh College Mission
Scandal yeah so Justice yeah low key
justice but but he's setting a tone like
first of all I'm going at y'all M I'm
she's not here so we could laugh a
little bit but you're it's going to be
for you too so get ready and yeah you
just got to go immediately calling them
all pedopile pedophiles like right up
top right up top like called that Jim
Gaffigan did that yeah that
gavagan so it's like you got to go right
and honestly maybe treat it like prison
like go at the Top Dog who's top dog is
it Tom Hanks at your
head I'm like hey if Tom Hanks is
laughing we all [__] do it or if he's
there upset I'm not you know it's going
to come to you as well yeah you know if
it's uh what's the guy that made
Oppenheimer Chris Nolan Nolan
Christopher Nolan love Christopher Nolan
but that movie
was an
atrocity
well I'm just saying I it's like the
fact that that like it has all the
things that should make it good it has
Christopher Nolan my favorite director
ever it has Killian Murphy one of the
best actors alive it has Robert Downey
Jr one of the other best actors alive
like everything should be good here mhm
but you watch it and you would rather be
in
Japan during the explosion of those
nukes than watching this movie you
really hat it that much that seems so
crazy I was envious of the people in
Nagasaki that's I was envious I don't
know if that's true I'm being honest I'd
watch I was watching that movie I was
like oh if I could only be in Nagasaki
or Hiroshima right now can you imagine
Andrew delivering that joke right there
on stage in front Chris I would love it
now here's the thing it would have to be
even it would have to be bet it have to
be like a real good joke I'm trying to
think like what do you say to
Nolan God I don't know and these guys I
mean it's their art they're taking it so
serious you know it's like imagine
somebody criticizing you know your
favorite joke J that you poured a year
two years of your life into like it's
well the Leo joke that Ricky did was
[__] was like a similar kind of prise
but like that's the kind of thing it's
like super you say a joke so that we can
remind people it's basically like uh I
forgot what movie he was oh the Irishman
he's like the Irishman was great it was
long though it was pretty long I mean it
was so long uh by the time I finished it
Le Leonardo caprio's day was too old for
him this is okay first of all so many
things why the joke is perfect greaty
for me delivery is amazing thank you two
you get rewarded as an audience member
for knowing things you're only laughing
if you know that Leonardo Caprio stops
dating him at 25 so as an audience
member you're like oh I'm smart I know
things right two the joke ain't about
the movie being bad right the joke is
about Leo and his sexual proclivities of
course ay knows the movie is long you
know I mean he made it so it's not
offensive to him he's like yeah it is
long yeah the only problem was Leo had
to break up with his girlfriend which he
was already going to do
that's that's great so crazy has Leo
ever denied that he's just like yo all y
think that about me I'mma keep young
[__] he probably likes it you right his
reputation precedes him every time he
meets a girl he's like you know what
this isn't have to explain nothing oh
man and every girl that dates him is
like I'm going to be the one I'm going
to go the distance every girl that dates
him is like I'm going to be the one and
they feel the birthday come up they act
extra nice I would love to see a biopic
of like the last six months of all the
relationships cuz you know the girl is
just going hammered trying to keep it
keep it locked in yeah I would love to
see I want to see drive to survive but
it's just it's just the girls like
trying to make it last in the
relationship with Leo cing every morning
they try to change their birth
certificate and [__] what you mean
believe this another year told you I'm
Colombian look I'm actually 20 is this
amazing funny yeah I want to see that
dud that'd be beautiful anyway so stay
up Joe you going to be all right man oh
the one thing I didn't like that he did
was try to use the Riders as a scapegoat
when the joke didn't work oh yeah like
don't don't point that out because it's
like I'm sure the writers worked hard on
those shits too and now you're going to
be like oh my shit's funny but everybody
else sucks and I think that was like but
I'm I I don't know how that that's the
thing you feeling felt the sweat from a
from feeling like you're bombing yeah so
that's and I think it might have been
like I mean I've been
in yeah I've been here before give 20
minutes I was be like who wrote this bro
[__] put this outfit together
everything sucks but yeah I think it's
like a that's like okay how can I call
out what's happening in the room like
how can I have this honest moment but
there's probably a little defensiveness
you know going on as well and uh yeah
it's a high stakes moment bro it's live
it's live and it's it feels like it's in
front of the world kind of is I mean
nobody gives a
[__] to be honest it's probably viewed
more because of the negative reaction
than if it went great yep if it went
great less people would see it yeah
that's true more people know about Joe
Coy now yeah yeah which maybe maybe it
works out yeah maybe it works out and
then they go to the show and they're
like oh this is awesome like it might
actually like work out for him I also
think that the reaction was so negative
that if you hear that first and then go
see it it's not close to as bad as how
awful Twitter made it seem yeah like
Twitter made it seem like not a single
human being left he he went at Taylor
Swift that was the thing like he had one
super like it was that must have been
later cuz that wasn't part of it's not
in the monolog it's in like an in inlude
what he say he says what's the
difference between the NFL and the
Golden Globes the Golden Globes has
fewer cutaways to Taylor
Swift That's the joke now you need to
come harder if you go at T swizzy and
she just she just took a sip didn't
didn't react didn't laugh they didn't
cut I thought she was in on it by you're
really going to do that on camera it
needs the joke needs to be so biting
that they have to make a decision in the
moment am I somebody that has no sense
of humor about myself or or am I someone
that can laugh about myself so and most
times Hollywood people will go I want
people to think that I have a sense of
humor about myself so they might even
fake the laugh but if it's not biting
then they could just look at you and be
like yo you're joke bombed and everyone
in the room is looking to that person
for confirmation am is it okay to laugh
at this one cuz I still want to be in
your good graces what do we do about
what would we what is the what is the
Taylor Swift joke so he does that and
it's not super like he doesn't come
super hard and then as a result all the
swifties on the internet like this guy
who is this guy blah blah so I think
that was where part of the disordinate
reaction came from I mean yeah the Swift
joke that's like the likable fun one is
playing into the we don't know who
Travis Kelsey Is MeMe that kind of
started like the Tik Tok challenge like
Taylor Swift's boyfriend y Taylor
Swift's boyfriend like that's the
likable sweet one that Taylor's going to
laugh at the Taylor fans are going to
find hilarious and then you you would
connect that to an acting couple M or
something sorry then you connect that to
like an acting couple or like a
directing couple where we know one more
than the other and then you kind of flip
it and then here's something we could
all laugh at and this is kind of cute
this with George Clooney sometimes his
wife is like a yeah is like a human
rights lawyer right and so people be
like like I I someone actually did a
joke similar to that at like her at his
recognition for some award or something
they're like his wife saved these people
did this did this did
and we're giving George Clooney a
lifetime achiev something remember and
so it's like some version of that you
could tie together and make a banger job
yeah perfect and then that's a fun
likable one and then there's one that's
actually stinging that's like um marks a
better looking woman than she is I mean
this guy is
crazy got a compliment needs to be it
needs to be at least would look better
that's what I'm say needs to be at least
a little
clever can't just be
it can't just be me it can't just be I
came in with the Cat Williams right now
yeah maybe there's something about like
you know how she will do an album about
all her exes yeah yeah yeah so then may
and I think we probably joked around
this on the show but like uh you know
something about like Taylor's already
found uh 20 different ways to rhyme CTE
oh yeah yeah you know what I mean like
playing off of what she's going to write
about
yeah yeah maybe not
that I was trying to bail
you maybe not that show the maybe not
that these [__] writers bro the
problem is these [__]
writers you can go to prix.com use the
promo code Schultz SZ you're going to
get 100% deposit match up to
$100 think about that okay you put in a
100 they're match with a 100 then you go
get your prize picks on make sure you go
to prize picks.com use that promo Cod
Schultz let's get back to the show